how does anti-racism harm black people
then
in many ways so for example all of the
effort that we are devoting to
quote-unquote defunding and reforming
the police
all
at least 70 percent of that effort
should be going into solving cases of
homicide within black communities to
giving really special attention to the
to the organizations in those
communities that are working to defuse
violence it ought to be a national
marshall plan and so you harm black
people by focusing instead on the
occasional stray white cop you harm
black people if
you see that black boys commit more
violence in public schools than any
other boys and that they therefore get
suspended more which is true
and you see that and instead you say
that the only reason they're getting
suspended more is because of bias
despite the fact that the data does not
support that at all and therefore you
see schools starting to be more lenient
with violent black boys and therefore
the other
black kids in the schools get beat up
more and their grades go down all of
which is documented and you watch all of
that happening and still keep on
enjoying that you can use three b's in a
row by saying the bigotry against black
boys and you can get a certain kind of
crowd to applaud
the way that debate is is conducted
is racist because you're basically
making it so that black kids get beat up
more while you call yourself anti-racist
by saying that there must be bigotry
against black boys and people clap
that's racist behavior and the book goes
on and on in that vein i would say that
the chapter on that is the longest one
because i wrote woke racism not to make
somebody like sean hannity clap it is
not written for the fox news crowd and i
didn't write it just to describe the
birth of a new religion the description
of that i've done that in a couple of
articles that it was boring to write
that part i've said that what i want to
write is that this new religion
is harmful it's not just that it's
excessive i'm not asking people to try
to understand each other because i don't
think the elect are subject to any kind
of constructive discussion i'm saying
that to let these people do what they do
is racism in itself i don't think that
people realize that because they're so
afraid of these people but that those
are the stakes here
why is this world view so popular then
if if people are afraid and it really
does feel like it's quite detached from
reality
why is the worldview so popular
yeah
if you're white it feels good to have
something all figured out if you're
white and you're not religious it feels
good to have another one
if you're white it feels really good to
show that you're not racist i can very
much imagine being a white person and
feeling it very important to show that
for example it's very important to me to
show that i'm not sexist yeah the last
thing i want is for somebody to call me
a male chauvinist and i would say that
there's a bit of me that sometimes even
puts blinders on as to why what might be
the occasional inconvenient truth i just
want to show that i am not a sexist
because frankly i'm scared i can tell
that's the way white people feel about
the race issue and then if you are a
black person
to frame yourself as an eternal victim
gives you a sense of belonging it gives
you a sense of significance if you're
lacking a sense of it for some other
reason it's no surprise that a lot of
black people feel insecure to an extent
because of the history of the race if
you are a noble victim which is the only
possible if you're not one you can't
wallow in victimhood if you really are
suffering from day to day but once
you're okay to frame yourself as a
victim in some abstract way feels good
it's a cloak and i completely understand
people you know taking that cloak and
wearing it there is a victimization
complex that is a human
trait it is a way that human beings can
go wrong where you you fetishize
victimhood you exaggerate victimhood
because being the victim gives you a
sense of absolution
and significance
this race the black american race has
encouraged the od on that so combined
white people looking to show that
they're not racist and black people who
build an identity not all black people
but enough who build an identity around
their
depiction of themselves as victims that
doesn't really fit modern society and
you've got this new religion where
terrible things end up happening for
reasons that can't be coherently
defended
at the end of the day
if it negatively affects black people
and black communities you would imagine
that after a while there would have to
be pushback i know that some of the
statistics to do with police with
murders in inner cities is directly
correlated with how many police are on
the streets and i remember reading an
article and they said this may be an
uncomfortable statistic but it seems
like the best way to reduce homicides is
to put police back on the streets and
you think well
i i don't understand why it's
uncomfortable if if someone has made a
hypothesis
that
getting rid of the police will make the
streets safer and that turns out to be
wrong there's nothing uncomfortable
about it it's only uncomfortable for the
people that had attached their sense of
well-being and ideology and self
to the outcome of this it's just it's
just wrong
yep
and a critical mass of the people who
argue for this quote unquote defunding
of the police don't live in those
neighborhoods and i want to give props
to the ones who do there's a certain
kind of person who talks that way who
does live in neighborhoods where they
listen to cop cars and you know they
they know that people have been killed
not too terribly far away but even with
those people the ideology reigns and so
they'll say something like well it's not
like we need no cops but the ideology
means that they have to be anti-cop and
that's the problem ideology can be a
really dangerous thing when it comes to
people
in bodybags and it also there's a
condescension involved where you've got
this woke person and this could be a
white one or a black one or a latina or
an asian one who thinks that the police
need to be reined in the police need to
be defunded
and then you have say the black
grandmother who has watched legions of
kids being killed by other kids who she
knows saying no i want more police and
nobody disrespects that woman to her
face but she's generally thought of as
somebody who doesn't know what's good
for her she doesn't understand the
larger picture and if the larger picture
is just that we're sad about george
floyd something that happened one night
in minnesota to one man and we're not
going to look at the larger picture
that's religion and so it means that
that grandmother is probably a devout
christian that woke college professor is
a devout elect he's even more religious
than her but he doesn't know it
it really does feel like anti-racism
treats black people like simpletons and
cretins
like that's how it feels it feels like
they say look no no no no you don't need
to worry about what's good for you
we know
we know what's good for you just put
your faith in us
that yep and [ __ ] isn't used as much
in american english and so i don't put
it that way but i wish it were because
yeah
anti-racism treats black people like
dum-dums and yet you see so many black
people including the very smartest ones
just lapping it up because the
victimhood complex is a powerful
attractant to all human beings we all
know professional martyrs it's human and
so
once you've settled into that and that's
your comfort zone you will accept any
amount of condescension as long as you
can consider to think of yourself as a
perpetual victim it's a nasty social
cocktail
do you have any idea about how much
credit are you enjoying the use of
credit i'll just anglicize everything
for the rest of the day talk about cups
of tea and stuff fish and chips um all
right governor
have you got any idea about how the
black community's views on racism and
anti-racism are split i'm aware the
black community is not some person that
we can just go and speak to it's not an
individual mass that we can survey but
you have any ideas around this
i do
if you survey the black community as in
people who have phds and write for the
major media organs
you would get the impression that the
black view except for the occasional
weirdo like me
is that racism in our era is largely
unchanged since 1960 it's just that
people are more polite and they've been
you know the dec the deck chairs have
been rearranged on the titanic you would
think that is the way everybody thinks
the minute you go out into the real
world you find that it's different i
know that from my own family i know that
from listening to people on the subway
in new york which is a great way to get
a sense of the real world you know we
don't drive here we sit on the train and
most of the people on the train do not
have the salary or the the circumstances
of somebody like me and you just listen
and you find that the actual view of the
community
many intelligentsia understand there's a
certain social conservatism
among ordinary black people but i don't
think they fully understand that
ordinary black people are not not nearly
as subject to this victimization complex
as
educated people are the professional
victim at say the black barber shop
that's one or two people that's a type
and often it's somebody who's
self-educated and has read a lot of the
things that people in the media and the
university right the bookish person who
maybe didn't go to college but you know
reads
that's where you get that sort of thing
then there's kind of a street corner
element
certain religious figures certain
churches but that's not the default i
remember um it's almost like somebody
wrote this for me it was like but i know
they weren't performing for me there was
a black couple who were sitting next to
me on the train i think they had a child
together and there was a sign on the new
york subway for a while where they
showed five different authors
um most of them of color and i forget
why but it was advertising five books
and it was some sort of initiative from
a library or something like that all
five of the books were very much the
ones that today's intelligentsia
argue are the good ones about race like
one of them was tanahasi coates book um
between the world and me and four others
that were kind of like that and they had
other authors holding them up
enthusiastically as if these books
needed advertisement it was a rather
insufferable sign but it was just there
for about six months and i remember
listening to this this couple
and the woman just said rocking the
carriage i get the feeling she wasn't
college educated and she said dem is all
lib did she say damn no she said those
are all liberal books
and she had this frown on her face and i
don't think her husband quite got it but
she said those are all liberal books how
come they can't have different kinds
even she got it that this there's a bias
in this sign as if the only relevant
black books are the ones that say that
the world is going to hell i don't think
she was that unique but you would never
know she existed based on the sorts of
people we're talking about this is an
intelligentsia issue for the most part
she needs to get on twitter if you got
on twitter everyone would know about her
opinion we should find i almost wanted
to say who are you but i didn't want to
sign you up for a twitter account
because i will do that
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace